willkommen bei philo cast die folge
heute geht um die frage wie man
abschlussarbeiten schreibt im
allgemeinen das heißt bachelor master
und auch die situationen da kannst du
einfach mal ja ein paar tipps geben und
grundsätzliche anregungen dazu wie man
daher an genau also wir hatten ja schon
ein video gedreht zum thema wie schreibe
ich richtig hausarbeiten das ist hier
verlinkt dieser box aber heute wollen
wir uns damit abschlussarbeiten befassen
also bachelor wieder richtig sagte
master und doktorat das ist nämlich ein
bisschen anders bei solchen
abschlussarbeiten der schreibprozess und
der konzeptionsphase was gefragt wie
schreibe ich am besten eine
abschlussarbeit da frage ich mal ganz
allgemein an frühzeitig sich schon mit
dem thema befassen und frühzeitig schon
kontakt zu einem betreuer und einer
betreuerin aufzunehmen das ist nämlich
ganz wichtig bei solchen
abschlussarbeiten
man muss eine betreuerin betreuer finden
mit dem man sehr gut fachlich aber auch
persönlich zurecht kommt weil man diese
personen längere zeit in kontakt stehen
muss verstehe ja dass auch dass wenn man
jetzt regelmäßigen kontakt pflegt wie
wirkt sich das auf die themenfindung
oder dem bearbeiteten jahren also man
kann zum beispiel meine sprechstunde
gehen von einer dozentin und einem
dozenten vielleicht könnte man die auch
schon durch die teilnahme an einem
seminar häufig ist es so man hat eine
hausarbeit geschrieben
bei diesem dozent und sagte oder würde
ich aber gerne eine abschlussarbeit raus
machen dann sollte man möglichst früh
kontakt aufnehmen
vielleicht mit den sprechstunden gehen
oder vielleicht mal ein kleines kurzes
exposé erstellen um was es geht und beim
exposé gilt dasselbe wie bei der
verabreichung von hausarbeiten in meine
leitfrage entwickelnde forschungsfragen
also häufig sind meine abschlussarbeit
dass kandidaten so dass sie zu weit das
thema wählen das geht jedem so man
interessiert sich für dieses thema und
kommt dann letztendlich gar nicht
richtig auf den punkt als ich ein
bisschen konzentrieren was ist das
eigentlich entscheidende das
problematische an diesem thema und damit
dann frühzeitig kontakt herstellen
ok die leitfrage wird als erstes
definiert genau ausgesucht
ja wenn man meine leitfrage hat und das
ist gar nicht so einfach eine leitfrage
zu finden häufig wechselt man die frage
noch ein probleme verändert sich im
laufe der zeit wenn wir eine gute
spezifische leitfrage hat dann sollte
man sich versuchen an so ein zeitplans
begeben den man am besten auch mit dem
betreuer der betreuerin abstimmt also
was mache ich zuerst welche literatur
sich hinzu wieviel sekundär texte wie
viel primär texte nämlich was ist der
zentrale bezugs text wenn es den gibt
wie viel zeit verplant für die recherche
lieferzeit für die niederschrift und wie
viel zeit für die interaktion das sollte
man auch nicht unterschätzen man braucht
dann auch ziemlich viel zeit um die
arbeit noch mal durch überschauen noch
mal vielleicht um zu formulieren und zu
einem guten ende zu bringen also
vermutlich länger als einen tag wo das
ja ja also da deutlich genug zeit
einplanen um den zeitplan gerne auch mit
dem betreuer abstimmen und es gibt
natürlich unterschiede zwischen bachelor
master und dissertation ja obwohl sie
letztendlich recht ähnlich sind
was wären denn der der hauptunterschied
zwischen bachelor arbeit und der
maßarbeit zb erstmal der umfang ganz
eigene bachelorarbeit herr zwischen 30
und 40 seiten ich hatte auch schon
bachelorarbeit mit 70 seiten natürlich
ist klar aber es eher beschränkt
dementsprechend kann das thema nicht so
umfassend sein
die masterarbeit ist umfassend sie hat
dann so 80 70 80 seiten ungefähr das
doppelte und dementsprechend muss man
sich viel intensiver mit dem thema
auseinandersetzen
aber prinzipiell sind sie sehr ähnlich
strukturiert und braucht eine leitfrage
und wir brauchten überzeugen die
gliederung die diese leitfrage sehr gut
ab handelt wenn du jetzt sagst das so
gesehen detailliert die fragen die
einzelnen fragen an gehst könnte man
sagen dass
maßarbeit zum beispiel einfach eine
angliederung von mehreren kleinen haus
arbeiten ist das würde ich nicht sagen
also der unterschied zur kleinen haus
arbeiten besteht eben darin dass eine
master weil ein großes thema hat ein
sehr komplexes thema was wir nicht mit
vielen kleinen themen erreichen wenn wir
die einfach zusammen nehmen sondern es
ist ein größeres thema ein
anspruchsvolleres thema komplexes thema
was dementsprechend auch eine
überzeugende gliederung braucht eine
komposition diese verschiedenen aspekte
und teil probleme dieses größeren themas
identifiziert und im zusammen blick
abhandelt also ist doch was anderes
ok danke jagd ist viele punkte genannt
die werden sicher hilfreich sein für
viele leute da draußen und ich freue
mich auf die nächste folge von vieles
mehr